life hacks 108 I sold a MacBook drenched
in porn I might just do porn there are
some life hacks that just are so
requisite on there that like well they
feel primitive to us now when I look
back at 101 and one or two justices
someone flowers notifications on the
phone you think you are such a basic
person you just being dragged around by
it I drag see now I want your attention
exceedingly excuse me then you watch
them pick up the phone you know I makes
what you did what we gonna do that
before that happened or not known okay
someone's message now know someone
hasn't messaged you someone's messaged a
bunch of a 12-8 book in a [ __ ] group
ginger over in general marginal gains
don't matter but that's that's reason
why marginal gains matter some of these
life hacks are dangerous have your
birthday notifications on for facebook
people that's brutal if you've got like
5,000 friends yeah it is
so this is the tip which is use people's
birthdays as a chance to review whether
you want the mini of life on us
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by Joni a new surf from propane
fitness car and it's life hacks
1:08 big one
thank you very much to the protein works
for sponsoring the last episode if you
want to grab any of the products that we
mentioned in that episode is in the show
notes below and today the lovely people
from your best self are giving away two
six minute Diaries you'll have heard of
speak about the six minute diary diary
you'll heard to speak about them before
if you want to get into journaling or
you already do it and you want the level
it up or you've already got a six minute
diary and you just want a new one
there's two of them available here one
in blue and one in pink am I gonna give
those away I didn't know that came in
colors well to the lucky boy and girl if
you want to enter all that you need to
do is leave a review on iTunes I'm not
going to say that it has to be five
stars because I'm pretty certain that's
against their Terms of Service but yeah
I mean let's let's be realistic here if
you leave a one star it's gonna be less
likely that you're gonna get have the
diary but you don't have to leave you
can leave whatever you want head on why
tunes and leave a review on the modern
wisdom podcast and if you are listening
on any other device go on a Macbook
borrow someone else's MacBook and login
on some ideas for it out saw your life
oh yeah we'll be giving away something
on the next one may be something that's
on stitcher or whatever people are not
Android ease so yet we also said that we
were going to choose a winner right I'll
just I'll ask that from last time for
one hundred and fifty pounds of protein
works and I think it needs to be dads
Charles otherwise known as Darren Morley
on YouTube who suggested the LD low-fat
ready meal range and most ready meals
are really crap I tried these out and I
have to say very impressed with really
fun so glad LD have got on the I think
he's sent he actually sent in some
suggestions of which ones he liked the
most
yeah I remember seeing that was three in
the comment five bean chili sweet potato
curry and Moroccan vegetable stew he
also suggested micro dosing
which haribol idea what was it that you
cert eat it's the equivalent of eating
some nuts and bolts in an effort to
trying to up your iron content yes like
it's such a sledgehammer the thing to do
to take a little bit of like I know it's
really popular and fancy in Silicon
Valley the same way that like avocado is
good for the gym and stuff but but it is
a very powerful potentially
destabilizing molecule that we don't
hasn't really been like rigorously
tested with people at least caffeine you
know what you're getting and it
ultimately the people say they take they
micro dose and it has a similar effect
of caffeine so just take a few yeah stop
it oh the other notable ones Sarah
charlatan but it's not a zombie he'll be
dealing with this other notable ones
Sarah Charlton Kretschmer when taking
pills
chin up for tablets and chin down for
capsules because the tablets sink while
capsules float that's someone who knows
that girls are [ __ ] tablets someone
suggested what why is it any different
well because you need to get with it so
if you have something that floats and
you tilt your head back you know it's
going to be the front of your mouth
while you're trying to swallow water
uh-huh
whereas if you do it with something that
sinks that we find and if you do the
reverse it'll be fine
although tilting my head down mmm good
and trying to swallow and it's quite
difficult okay but I don't think the
buoyancy of the give the capsule is
stronger than your capacities hominoid
diet happy loves low soup and writers
yeah get some powder free nitrile gloves
for the kitchen for all meat preps or no
hand Washington needed we already talked
about this they'll just need to use
scissors single hand still gonna handle
the meat I never touch meat I just I
just dip it into my pressure cooker it's
already chopped you can bite you can now
by
pre-chopped me to the butchers have
their nitrile free gloves very life hack
I drop life hack dry socks quickly by
putting a hairdryer in them dry in about
20 to 30 seconds areas as well so I
think break ahead you know how sometimes
hairdryer
like it'll buy ya a big bada boom some
of these life hacks are dangerous yeah I
mean my advice would be if you want find
out more of these submitted life hacks
heads to life hacks one of seven link
will be in the show notes below and I'll
see ready meals yes Mike reducing LSD
yeah you need to come along and blowing
up your hair dryer you need to go on
YouTube have a look at these but that's
enough about the past it's time to talk
no one said any for yourself today I
specifically said please someone send us
one for you so if I'm pretty certain
there's a few and most of them what by
air pods oh you know how close we were
to binding you up on I would have been
very upset well I would have sold them
on I think your market was doing like a
twenty pound box I would have upset me
Chris right I'm gonna start because you
do really yeah yeah um I'm gonna start
today and first one I'm gonna go for is
whiten your teeth so whitening your
teeth is kind of become a caricature of
itself of like someone who probably uses
Brylcreem still and and has that that
has like yeah like a quiff at the front
like the guys at the inbetweeners
however I am going to propose that
whitening your teeth or making your
teeth whiter is probably one of the
easiest ways to make yourself just have
a bit more confidence and look a bit
more polished and attractive both in
meetings for business personal like to
the other sex or to the same sex it's
just for the people that I know that do
it I notice because I do I know you so
the people that have like over white
teeth or particularly whitey and they're
just the way that their smile is put
together to me looks much more well
polished literally if you are interested
in how you can do that I would advise if
you want to spend money if you want to
spend big money then the cosmic dental
clinic in Newcastle has my buddy David
working there I'm sure that he'll sort
you up but a much easier way is crest 3d
white strips you can just buy them you
know I don't think they're available on
Amazon in the UK but crest 3d white
strips you can get like a 2-pack
fifteen quid or 20 quid and you just
leave them on for about three to six
hours and you'll have like noticeably
whiter tea don't [ __ ] about with
whitening toothpaste or anything which
isn't bleach basically as far as I can
tell from someone who knows what he's
talking about and does the teeth of half
of Newcastle football team David hmm
anything which isn't bleach is mostly
bollocks later whitening is bollocks
those little like USB sticks that you
put in your mouth that you see Conor
McGregor promoting is also bollocks just
think I've seen you with a blue thing in
your mouth like a blue that was when
that was when a lady used to come round
to the office and do it and as soon as
David was like make what you do need
just wasting your time so shoot this
lady would come up and do all of the
lads in the office for free like just if
you post on social media yeah and I was
like whoa brilliant and David was like
do you actually think that your teeth
look that much whiter compare them with
when you bleach them and like mmm yeah
it might be a bit placebo going on that
that bollocks don't it so I have tried
this before okay and I did it with my
dentist and it was expensive and it gave
me over sensitive teeth that happens so
the way to get around the way to get
around oversensitive teeth best way to
do it and this is what David would say
is by some Sensodyne rapid relief put by
a gum shield put a little bit sense of
that rapid relief in the gum shield pop
them over your teeth for about 10
minutes then take out dry your teeth so
you need to be dry put your strips on
take it off put the gum shield back on
again because it to the dentine which is
what's actually sensitive but that helps
to reduce the sensitivity and just keep
on smashing sound I think and this is
probably wrong but this is right my
basic understanding is that it because
you teeth a porous yeah sensitive
toothpaste makes it less porous or
blocks they get holes
yeah and then the acid doesn't seep into
the other paint that says bleach doesn't
yeah get into the dentin as easily yet
but that's I've got hypersensitive teeth
as well right and you're alright with it
I just need to be careful with how long
I use it for right
as long as they don't absolutely pound
it I have really bad memories over the
dentist told me to leave them on
overnight and to put this stuff in a gum
shield way oh yeah and use the next
morning's agonizer couldn't drink waters
awful so I use an overnight gel for
three hours
Wow so I'm using it for less than the
Hashi time and even that gives me little
twinges we got that with the Sensodyne
I'm like I'm sweet to set time away and
you'll learn like once you've done it
once like we get like after you know
three treatments maybe is so much wider
it's just I think it's a it's a good
start I agree I think it's an easy
upgrade hundreds they make it work
nobody thinks again yes if there's this
sort of thing you might have a construct
under the crust
yeah no stress this with colonies ones
but yeah
quitting coffee as well like just
stopping the things that are staining
your teeth in the first place does once
no milk in coffee reduce the staining
because I whenever I split me tends to
Alice they would say avoid black coffee
and when I say does not mean having milk
removes it and they go yeah okay
David if you're listening can you please
come again answer please thank you mate
right Johnny
I haven't hopped I told you this time
you knew it was coming warm potato
always coming around with is held for a
while yep have we mentioned Wi-Fi skills
before maybe in life hacks one I think
it was one or but but I think it's worth
let's bring out again okay so there now
I'm Nakia Nakia bought Withings or why
things but Wi-Fi scales are so if you
weigh yourself every day just a pre mark
or Primark Primark yeah me too I think
people that say pre market Psychopaths
and people that leave suds on the dish
after they psychopath sure yeah sorry
yes okay but with interesting point um
so I think everybody should be weighing
themselves daily regardless of your goal
we were speaking about every article
there's just bodybuilding isn't it
everyone has probably everyone has a
bodybuilding builder do we were speaking
about this recently that it's one of the
it's like a health marker that no a GP
might ask about for example you know he
lost any weight recently
bladezz might rent if you're weighing
yourself like once every four days like
how the hell do you know so a lot of
random data points but anyway so the
problem with weighing yourself normally
is he standing the scales you step off
the scales you get the shower you have a
poo and you're like what is sitting it
and you can't remember withing scales or
Wi-Fi scales just take it into an app
and graph it and they were under quit
but you're brilliant feeling to stand on
the scales and know that it's just gone
mm-hmm yeah Ames I'm sure it t
MyFitnessPal I've had mine for five
years now and that's still working I
thought it's broken
they were there aren't enough right I
will sit like that they are still
working you know the precise weight of
your cleaner so okay so we have just
refreshed the scales so they've been
there for five years so this is the
reason that it's on there is I've just
read up and bought the same scales again
and interestingly five years Devin they
may even change them it's inside of just
not yet isn't that fascinating
Wow well that means I've got it right
yeah so they're exactly the same
they might measure like a button as well
um you yeah not feel remissed about that
that they haven't changed yeah no it
means I bought the right product they
measure like the co2 my body fat
percentage they measure it they tell me
what the weather is going to be they
graph my weight over of course today
radio so back has a profile I have a
profile and there's a few unassigned
measures that don't fit like if it's
like 90 kilos I'm glass not Johnny
heavier than that
get over there were loads of 80 kilo
entries hmm always Tuesday 1:00 p.m.
when you start to like the first
thoughts like panicking like he was
getting it on a bedroom god yeah cleaner
so I have a not only do I have a few I
didn't wait to clean it I actually have
it in the glass that she has no idea
that I have you know and it's not
I feel voyeuristic but I found helpful
it's being chart on my phone yeah
inside Andy you might pick up on a red
flag of the cleanest health before the
trend line in her weight co2 it's
actually so when we had a lecturer while
ago he said that he saw a woman in a
bowling alley was he I was bowling with
my children and I saw a woman with
Promethea which we discussed in the last
episode hello sorry to disturb you but
I'm an endocrinologist and you you have
a few of the features of something we
call acromegaly which is excess growth
hormone production in it and and she was
nervous the first island that man I
think you should probably go to see a
doctor about it she did did you become a
cougar apparently so and then also just
laser Sadie sang on the bus next to
someone and smelt bacterial vaginosis on
the woman next to it and just said I'm
really sorry but you like you mean what
to gnosis I think I'd rather someone
told me that my vagina smells then
harness you know it was vagina vagina
produce signature it is it honestly it
is such a distinctive smell it like any
describe it's like someone's buried a
fish in a warm warm climate wrapped in
some like cheap squeezie cheeze you know
the squeezie cheeze that you get in like
a achieve toothpaste tube so it hits
some of the high notes on smell then yes
not a low smarts not musky no no it's a
full spectrum smell oh yeah it digs into
your nose and it does not go away I
viewed a flat three years ago you told
me about this was someone who'd been in
it before it had this was she so that
there was in there was a girl sighting
paired with her boyfriend and I went
into the room and it's just the air is
thick with bacterial vaginosis re for
the the guy like the trapped but he
should you should tell there should be
like four maybe he's both of our sakes
maybe he's become like
- it was it just a party reinfection
yeah Stockholm Syndrome that people have
he's got like the bacterial version of
Scots consulate he loves the back to
next 36 hours you'd have like you know
like little phantom whips and you're
like telling you my power of bleach and
everything you just can't get it out why
is it just on Wi-Fi skills this wouldn't
happen yeah
what is clitoral megali negra large
black clitoris what Court is it bruising
it's much bruising snatch snatch causes
clicker I'm a green egg room and if
surely that's only if because it
shouldn't you should be hitting there
should cubic gone man go you got to make
contact you're not behind does that mean
every Olympic weightlifter come on speak
miss a big black raised Johnny so I'm
blessed and that was there's too much
glance on glands oh megwin agram is a
black balint plans I wonder whether that
has any Google results probably not okay
that's not to look
search for glands Omega V mega room no
way I'm sorry no no we're not doing it
out glands omegle evening Graham sorry
there's never plays ball with face of
yours Johnny but I think we could have
derailed your life hack any further your
Wi-Fi scales Wi-Fi say Wi-Fi scale I was
so this was a problem George had
recently he was like I've been way
myself but I can't you know I wanna have
a screen free morning and I don't want
to have to go and log it whatever and so
I'm gonna keep a pen and paper next to
my scales and I said why the Rose Hill
under quit that the last year long time
wellsworth wild yeah so mine is you puck
have I this familiar just like Toby
sort of so have you ever been on a
YouTube video so in is actually like I
was being sarcastic it is actually yes
it's the one where it gives you it from
a different country when it says not
available yeah yes we've already to have
done that's what okay if X doesn't know
what that is you watching a YouTube
video and it goes like can't see it just
replace the word tube with pack PA K and
it will unlock the video for you
unbelievable if someone's managed to
mirror the entire unit site URL for URL
I'm so glad to have because it's so like
how many videos do you try and watch
though unavailable in your country it
must happen to me twice a year
yeah it's not it's not very often
parker's lows to me so finicky to the
whole thing you're watching okay Mar so
long since I've got another YouTube
related one which is just like Toby it's
it well so you have a if you like me you
have a lot of videos that you want to
like a lot of lectures or audio books or
whatever that you want to add to your
list your Q yeah and the watch later
function on YouTube is pretty rickety so
instead just set up a playlist that says
was called lectures or listening add
things to it and then you can get
YouTube resume er which is a Chrome
extension that every time you go on a
long videos like sometimes you might
have an audiobook which is a video of
five hours long you go on it and it just
jumps to the spot that you are up
previously why that's not a native
function of YouTube I have no idea but
just with some video yeah does it just
look a lot of my videos well if you go
to watch something that you've already
been watching Joey comes to it oh so
maybe isn't it a function up in nantes
and another plug-in that you have is
blocking that feature
maybe it's like way you have to take in
take medicine to counteract the side
effect of the medicine the medicine
feels like you discovered myself I think
that's I think for some videos
definitely it doesn't do it for some
videos it seems to again rickety you
just want to make sure you have the only
person in the room that we need to refer
to about this is the only one who can't
speak on camera which is the MD fee you
can signal to us or explained via dance
interpretive dance video dance team
BDD right my one so I go I've just been
away on holiday
quite a bit I've been going to new
restaurants different cafes and things
like that when you go especially up in
some places that have got quite
culturally not sensitive but food where
you think I bet there's something meant
on this menu but I need to [ __ ] ask I
need to work out like very very
carefully what it is Rome Boston why
there's a lot of seafood in Santa Monica
and Venice in LA so my life hack is ask
the waiter for the most popular dishes
so ask the waiter for suggestions about
what to order when they come over and
they bring you they ask you for your
drinks after you've looked perplexed at
the menu for a little while would you if
you are if the waiter said I can tell
you the most popular dish or I can tell
you the mo the best dish well that's
what what what's pinyon what's willing
to him who is it you know he knows then
I've got to I've got two choices and one
of them may meet my tastes someone that
may not one that might have loads of key
noir in it and I'm gonna [ __ ] off I see
because there's a lot of things that
many people do which are a bad decision
yeah but not usually with food it's the
same reason why going to a restaurant
which has lots of people in it is
usually a good idea when you're on
holiday actually that can be another
part of the life hack that when you're
looking for somewhere to eat abroad like
yeah you can Trip Advisor a google-like
review it but especially if you're
walking down the street like Rome's
perfect example of this is just
restaurants and cafes all over the place
just look for the one that's the busiest
like the one that's the busiest must
have something about it unless there's
it's the first time it's ever been busy
and everyone else's but brought this
heuristic into play if it'll be like the
way that reddit works where things just
get as critical mass from yeah an early
stage and then everyone starts there
but yeah so ask the waiter for
suggestions I've done this with drinks
and food in four cities over the last
month and every time that I've asked
them for suggestions it's been fantastic
yeah really good got a weird or steamed
octopus pasta in Rome
that would have never ever ordered most
popular dish in the place had a lobster
roll so if you can imagine lobster meat
that's been completely pulled free of
all of the shell put into a heavily
heavily buttered very soft bat like that
doesn't sound like a gourmet dish but
was in terms of taste and texture was
like a like a soft bun but massive yeah
right like that I think I know really
heavily but it that was unbelievable as
well yeah it's just it's really cuz its
outsourced a decision how sorts of
decision yeah or if you with especially
if you with people that go there all
times or would you want it or what does
ever else hold it about a good drink and
you just ask me like if anyone knows
it's the waiter or the waitress
it probably guarantees that it's fresher
as well if you order something rogue on
the menu that might have been sitting
around for a long time where are
something with a high turnover well then
there's no way that the waiter or
waitress is going to suggest you
something which is then going to result
in you going excuse me this doesn't
taste very fresh they're gonna have a
degree of like existential protectionism
and that's they've been told to sell or
the special [ __ ] we can't get rid of
this three-wheelers la I'm always that I
always think about our specials and
restaurants work that thing it is yeah
it's so what's gonna expire next well
why else would they do what a country
anyway Johnny keep it keep it fresh is
now so I have one that's about Facebook
cuts
can I say that yes sure so Facebook have
just launched a and this is interesting
to area everybody I suppose never from
new feature where you can press on any
post you see on Facebook you can press
in the top right to I the I it's
something it's something it's operate
pressing that you press why am I seeing
this post or why am I seeing this ad if
it's why my saying this ad you can see
so if you're a business owner you have a
Facebook page you can see who your
competitors are targeting and you can
see which targeting brackets you fall
into or if it's a page you can select
all kinds of options with that pay
with that person citizen what you can
just live customize your Facebook on
Facebook now you do that mother mm-hmm
thank you
that is useful if you just being at the
mercy of because that part of the reason
that we block our news feeds it's cuz
it's the fun that you don't want yeah
so if you see arts or see posts like if
you figure eight you you know what
that's essentially where others along
have a dictator to you you can you can
don't want to on a post from a business
page that say or an influencer that you
want to hear more of and bump that
person's awareness you can do with
organic and aren't enough like it's one
of my biggest gripes with Instagram for
example that it only seems to show you
posted from the same five people even if
you're even if you follow 800 so whereas
if you could choose the proportions that
you see people in rather than just like
them this kind of circular thing exactly
this is you are dear the 795 people are
obviously just posting [ __ ] content it
doesn't tip over that the other what do
you and consume what platforms of
channels do you consume like do you
consume a Facebook or Instagram and the
moment legit not like John Madison mess
I think it's my biggest it's a normally
here normally would you like when you
find yourself spending a long time in
Instagram or a lot for me and instagrams
my biggest time sink right but that's
where I Drive from my most traffic as
well so just business but also that's
the line gets very very blurred its I
get your arms easiest this is just like
so now yeah the guy that created like
window shopping and the guy that created
infinite feed says it's the biggest
regret of his life Wow God created
infinite feed yet the infinite scroll
feed like I says it's that it is
rangerous there's no extraneous like cuz
ya be there forever
it's that end is there now add to the
feed
although you can actually get to a point
on Instagram it says you're fully caught
up now and so on wonder who really gets
to that point well on modern mister by
only follows one person and that to me
so I very quickly catch up with all of
my own posts when I go on and what I
miss them
for the people who are tagging modern
wisdom iPhone Instagram I really
appreciate it
but just tag me instead because I never
go on now go on to see such and such
mention here in their story such and
such mentioned you in the story it's
always three days ago and I see so at
the very least tagged me as well
Thank You chef that's also a Facebook
related one which is have your birthday
notifications on for Facebook people and
what do you phone you can either set it
to linked with your calendar or just
have it on the right side of your thing
you can be blocking your Honda yeah
that's brutal if you've got like five
thousand front yeah it is so this is the
tip which is use people's birthdays as a
chance to review whether you want them
in your life on course it's a fantastic
to so when they come up you just like ah
actually [ __ ] off
yeah that's fantastic because I think a
birthday is a polarizing thing because
it instantly is like right I need to
make the decision do is this someone
that I need to go and say happy birthday
to in which case they are good and
important in your life do you not really
care in which case should you delete
them or are they someone that actively
if you were to say happy birthday to
them they would think it was weird and
so a lot of people there's some people
in there who I need to have on my
Facebook BIOS Adamo to wish happy
birthday there's some of the fun that
you know you have on your Facebook here
just okay is that I think the hockey
ahead of that is just don't be Precious
about your Facebook I think people just
need to stop being so precious about the
social media I didn't like just have as
many friends as what I just cannot do
you like don't people who like to think
their Instagram or their social media
like friends or whatever is an extension
of real life and like it can be if you
choose it to people it can also just not
be why are we talking about this the
other day with kids and snapchat you
know where like it is it the yeah was he
was a mug like the flames trees drinking
it so I unfollowed everyone on Twitter
vision everybody about a year ago and
then have very very slowly Amin I follow
60 people now and I have to say that my
life especially on Twitter which is high
volume stuff is bliss
that's absolutely bliss Ashton
but my point is that if you if you were
to have that degree right curated miss
with all of your students so if the
other day
Becca said are you know such and such
I'm I was friendly Kannada she was like
answers person on Facebook who you're
you meet your friend with him I don't
know but I said to her I bet you I know
who has more friends at me on Facebook
Chris yeah and you doing you have yep I
don't know a crazy number yep five
accounts and each one of them's about
$5,000 yeah so I have 1500 friends but I
maybe no I made me speak to 20 of them
yeah there was a period when it was a
useful resource but I think for me now
it doesn't really work as well I can't
scale individual connections with people
like that but it is still a powerful
resource like one way of doing
recruitment and stuff for freshers we're
still telling the boys like nothing
beats a big Facebook for the kind of
work that we do personal face to face
networking for a geographically
localized event and it went like big
Facebook account with a message people
directly exactly yeah
so I'm gonna do one and this is one
actually which is from not miss co-owner
sorry that's right sorry this is all my
she's actually from VMD so he sent me
this the other week um D which is
messenger calm so I didn't know that
messenger calm is facebook Messenger
without Facebook yeah so I don't need to
be on Facebook game distracted by
getting tagged in notifications and
invites to events and pages and just
general stuff or those scrolling music
playing videos and stuff like that but
messenger chrome allows me to in the
same way that whatsapp web works for
that so I now have a tab of all of my
stuff which is I can just go on and
check during a Pomodoro break or
whatever it might be
what's that web in messenger doc not
don't get distracted by notifications
still get all the functionality and a
better view as opposed to just that it's
even bigger than when you view it on
full Facebook it's even better than that
yeah so messenger doc you can find it
from inside Facebook I think if you just
press messages
it takes you to messenger come I think I
don't think it does I think it still
keeps the plan lesson yet I think it's
the frame off you use whatsapp web in
Chrome or do you have the Mac oh noes
are using Chrome right
do you prefer to do that yes because the
apps a bit hit miss for me sometimes
that's exactly why I don't use it so
it's firstly the apps buggy
mm and secondly turning off
notifications for it is more difficult
like it just it's more entrenched in my
system
cool turkey kills it just guess now yeah
so do you need because it mine will say
like you need your phone like the scan
the QR code is what type web do that as
well oh yeah there's only one sever but
there is a native version of messenger
comm called France fi as ed or goofy
which is like Arabic when you save
native native Mac I could see its own
curator is that so yeah so is it France
that does all of the different yeah okay
so that there is a messenger I think
there's one called goofy among called
something else France or something
different which just aggregates all of
your instrument searching stuff yeah I
mean Facebook you're gonna do that
themselves anyway soon they're gonna
integrate what's up Facebook Messenger
and Instagram that would be fantastic
yeah nothing would make me happier than
having to switch between they'll be on
separate apps yeah but just on one
Megara well I don't think I don't think
I'll make the motion
I bet it's a bet for the developers
they're having a anaphylaxis because of
the much the enormous yeah it'll be a
bit of difficulty in combining it but
then the total screen time will go down
total screen time will definitely go
down because I'm switching itself just
because they need they need infantry
they need space yeah so I mean the the
main reason that messenger calm and the
phlume are using flume for Instagram and
removing all of the tabs except thing
except for messages and like your own
profile and post maybe and the reason
whatsapp web works is you want to be on
receive as little as possible you want
to be on sand and only send because you
only want to send when you want to send
but you're on
receive into their heads to everyone
else back in the day when we were our
life hack turn off all notifications
I cannot imagine life with notification
there are some life hacks that just are
so requisite on there that like well
they feel primitive to us now when I
look back at 101 and one or two they're
like the slow cooker what just someone
flowers notifications on the phone
savage you think you are such a basic
person just your life you just being
dragged around by it like drive deep
it's terrible and grouped I want your
attention exceed any excuse and you
watch them pick up their phone you know
I may it's what you did what we gonna do
that before that happened or not known
okay someone's message now know someone
hasn't messaged you someone's messaged a
bunch of a 12-8 book in a [ __ ] group
just because I remember you not having
this conversation and I said I don't
want to turn it off because I need to
check it at some point and you said well
you you have to do have a cadence for
tracking but it lasts either something
you decide or someone else decides it's
so hard to write love sin' sam harris
meditation app we talked about that yes
you have we talked about it briefly but
not in as full depth as you someone
who's complete a fair bit of course okay
so I typically so I've just hit like 110
days I think I've meditated in a row and
it's drink I've been thanks I pause a
moment now to see if I get any from
across the husband sorry I was building
no family so I've been doing a lot of
that unguided and but I think for a
guided experience the Sam Harris thing
is the best that I've found and there's
a few reasons one is its progressive
throughout the 50 days whatever so he
introduces new consequences mean less
oppressive less in terms of the amount
he speaks but progressive also in terms
of like so he'll start off with focus on
the breath and then delivery takes that
attention and expands it to awareness
and then he starts talking about
notice who is noticing or what is
noticing telling the attention on the
that the self talks about like
implanting or like trying to alter the
frame of mind that you're reading all
these sorts of things and attorneys in
the arms it's down near little leg it's
not like headspace and it's only ten
minutes so I will typically do that to
begin a session and then do unguarded
after that so it is at you into the mmm
into the zoom it is pay that's a clever
way to do it to hybridize it without
being reliant on well the first ten
minutes is always rocky mmm well I think
the risk is the risk with meditate or
the risk with anything is practicing or
doing a [ __ ] practice because then
you're just entrenching in the right
yeah yeah so if you sit and do 30
minutes they should never do technique
work tired well so I suppose like if
meditation is the formal practice for an
awareness or a mindfulness and you do it
when you sit down and think and just get
lost in thought loss and thought I know
that you like to say that like well what
about done that yeah so I think talking
off with 10 minutes of lip this is the
correct well this is a sort of a way to
focus your your mind then allowing it to
go off I think for me at least has been
more productive so that app is fantastic
in my opinion and he is I think someone
said he would you want to listen to you
for meditation device he'd be he'd be up
there
yeah he's what he's I think he's a
definitely reputable in meditation
Authority isn't he and he's no he's not
there's no he's not sensations about
he's just like well I've looked at the
researcher so I've been searching sorry
you're gonna be quite during that I've
been searching through my phone and I
found the code modern wisdom all in
capital letters will give anyone who's
listening one-month free trial of full
access to waking up a zinger so as I
like to I spoke to Carl from support at
the beginning of this year and he said
that we can send you a promo trial that
will offer your listeners a free
one-month try
modern wisdom that's awesome there's
also so there's meditations there's
fifty days of meditation and then
lessons lessons as well which are just
sort of monologues on the first aspect
of life and it becomes a daily session
that is different every day
brilliant I like I like the idea of the
waking up thing I I'm beginning to be
moved around to your way of thinking
stuff to do with guided versus unguided
I think my initial problem with unguided
sessions was it was embedding bad habits
like what am i doing this sucks this is
this than the other but since I got a
meditation coaching have been following
a more structured program because I
don't know how much what you like about
guided meditation is the fact it's
guided and the fact it's structured so
what I like about sound stuff is the the
someone so I think the parts of
meditation that I started find difficult
are the searching for the self parts so
moving from breath into awareness and
then from awareness into you where is
the like the seat of attention I find
that quite difficult get my head around
where's the way slant does it as he
starts off like billy basics and then
gently introduces those concepts you
start at the seat if he putts and then
you think I buy the city any paths to
the seat of attention I see
scope so it's because it's progressive
that's what I like like wears head
spaces just hand you know so mine is if
you were Horace most unarmed Cyrus if
you are looking on YouTube my head is
that is just like Toby no it's similar
to Toby
so if you're looking at my head you
might be thinking oh what a wonderful
haircut I wish I could get a haircut
like that well let me tell you I had
this haircut in my own kitchen and that
was thanks to Chris recommending a
fantastic hair cutter called
Zara who comes to your house and curtsy
hair saves you having to wait in the
barber shop but you looking at me
because we've done this
for yeah okay next one get your haircut
at home was a life hack you adopted from
me talking about it on a past life I'm
fine well there's a cycle of life I
don't think that's really hurtful
I get my haircut once every six weeks
okay I'm the Christmas is going across
and the experience of going did I say
there's also no because I didn't know
what you're going to saying you're wrong
well you don't know that okay so I like
going to the hairdresser's because it's
I get to it's the same feeling for me as
like being on a plane it's a time out
and I get my head massage in a massage
chair
I get a sparkling water oh thanks no I
like doing Yousuf I actually like paying
more and being more inconvenienced as
well so yes is it inconvenienced that's
the question so were you sir did you
have to drive to the desert yeah how
long was it just time and money ten
minutes
both ways 20 minutes how long did it
take to get in and do the small talk 10
minutes 30 minutes 30 minutes you
already should give me the total time
I'll give you the total time I don't
care I'm talking about total wasted time
because I can't speed up the haircut
that much okay
but you had to get up
leave account for traffic deal with
traffic you get there small talk with a
bunch of women you have nothing in
common with drink true you're wrong well
hey how much you pay don't see quit [ __ ]
me you get two haircuts so two haircuts
in half the time
so this these arguments are four times
the value they're only valid if one you
are managing your finances to the extent
the you know exactly where every 30 quid
is going and to not really it just means
you have a preference for spending less
money compared to me you can't you can't
say that don't spend money on that
that's gamblers fallacy if you know it
isn't if it's like if you if you need to
know down to a degree of fidelity that
is 30 quid and it's it's a thirty quid
spend every six weeks okay so how many
people have that type of a hold on the
finances that
well my thirty quid that you as long as
it's getting anything for the extra
thirty quid like what I am I'm getting
an experience so okay well if you
enjoyed the course it makes me real to
get heading and again and again well so
what I love about Zara is that she
tolerates my weirdness and I just sit
and work while she's got my head so yeah
the other aspect to that what I was
saying was if if your time is that well
manage that in nineteen ninety minutes I
say every six weeks cannot be possibly
wasted no then again so I I just don't
like it for wasting time and money no no
no popping has a system all the matters
it's an allocation of those things so I
get an enjoyable experience you enjoy
the experience do you enjoy the driving
do you enjoy the driving Maron bike it's
fine but I know a thing I enjoy talking
about marginal games and refining things
isn't there also a sense of smugness
that you get just from having your hair
cut without having to go anywhere didn't
leave and that's also didn't have to get
changed didn't have to put my shoes on
didn't have to take them off again how
about we do six weeks where we miss
Brown we switch haircut one haircut I
sometimes get my hair cut in a place as
well do you get a muscle no do us
barking water but I remember there was a
place that dick give you a head massage
in Edinburgh and I used to work with the
Scottish guy and I came back and I was
like oh heck hurt in that place and so
oh I don't know that face instance see
me that's all I'm seeing just go because
there's a ten pounds I I like it because
I think it's a it's bitter being nice to
yourself like it sir I'm gonna go it
again she so for me here's my here's my
argument for that you're spending
fifteen quid extra every six weeks
mmm-hmm save that up go from go for a
massage yeah you are you are making
protein pancakes here well that is one
FS references that I've made that you're
assuming that I wanted they I like a
massage as much as I do a haircut but
you you're saying I like a haircut
because it's time to myself
answer and it's a pampering but
ultimately like you can't feel your hair
being cut
I agree and like you just you sat in a
silly little coat and you paying them
the killer for me is the overhead that
you're paying that you can't get around
the overhead in terms of 15 minutes or
10 minutes they're 10 minutes
[ __ ] at the beginning 10 minutes at
the end like that's half an hour so
every 12 weeks you have wasted the exact
amount of time and the exact amount of
money that I can get you an at-home
massage foot this is such a good advert
for Zara I think like an Sabina and
Sabina come round do the massage or you
well you could get Zara to do the
massage Sabinas to do the haircut see if
they both make an absolute terrible job
of it yes they will end
although Sabina wants to be a surgeon
and true so maybe she's got steady on
this the same issue that I had with
Alfred okay so if let's say over 12
weeks we all get the same amount done
but YouTube for example the solution
Chris suggested of saving if the extra
putting it into it an actual pampering
surely that but that's assuming that's
both of what you are saying is you are
wasting time there should be saved time
and money that should be saved and put
us on could be saved
precisely but my point is but I don't
think anybody does that and I think
those were so wasteful with our time and
money anyway I'm saying this I don't
cost fallacy I'm saying that I doesn't
think anybody has a Titan of control
over their time or money to say I'm not
gonna win this argument
you two are is it wrenched truck don't
trust so yesterday I was so like so
precious about time because I had a lot
to do in 90 minutes out of my day would
have been killer like it would have so
in a situation where you're revising for
finals for medicine okay but fair enough
but in general I don't think anyone
husband took Angele over in general
marginal games don't matter
but that's that reason why marginal
gains matter I haven't even got to my
life at because I've got a home so
here's exactly where you money okay so
here we go here's another one for that
one that I'm Darren my business partner
has adopted the Pomodoro Technique and
was singing the praises to in a group
chat with our other two directors saying
it changed his life then he said I'm
being dramatic but it's shaved
thirty minutes off my Monday tasks over
a 40 year career that's 43 full 24-hour
days or 130 working days that I've saved
if he is not if he's not using his time
down with fidelity of 30 minutes and
he's being wasteful in the week why
should he be bothered about that so
Johnny did a podcast recently called the
death by a thousand cuts which is he's
now being killed by erisa would honestly
think we're arguing about different
things okay
III think so because because I know you
you are a very logical person and this
seems really at odds with it so I think
I think we're probably not understanding
your you're gonna do you're gonna do is
we're gonna go away and we're gonna
discuss it and then in lifehacks 109 mm
what will all be converse these are the
same you'll be the same - no it'll be
gang persuade you to Thomas I drop my
hack in at home because you're wrong
well you know because we will be getting
a haircut you know expensive time I'll
be paying I'll be paying twice I'll be
paying twice as much to wait for twice
as long do you think that everything in
your life is done purely for purposes of
optimizing time money no some of its for
enjoyment as well because but I don't
I'm never going to enjoy it just do this
let's use CrossFit as an example yeah
is that the best use of time and money
for an enjoyment not that was there was
a three-mile enjoy okay okay I'm doing
roughly hewn it's all for last
actually I added enjoyment but Chris
said that enjoy is not because their
goal is absent strength or whatever
right so is that the best use of those
things the best I found compared to
other things that I've tried so it's
like it takes less time and less money
than other visions yes fitness so I
think you and I both know what about not
training therefore thus cost no time and
no money
well I won't achieve the outcome yeah
okay so suppose that discussion thanks
to Chris being a kind of reference for
me as well because obviously this is
someone who is coming to your house
doesn't know you you could be a predator
and so she called Chris because I was
through the reference you know hi
got a new inquiry from some local yusuf
is he a weirdo Chris like yes but not to
but it's not that kind of weirdo I don't
want to I don't a support of this story
Yousef but this literally was told the
reason that you feel like it's such a
funny story feels very dangerous because
it was on the trailer for the last life
was it right okay let's move on to your
life facts oh okay this might be a
repeat as well keep dental floss in the
shower yes yes yes okay a hundred you
know why this is it you haven't format
did you like [ __ ] yeah me your life act
for you life acts okay when you finished
in the shower this is a little repeat
isn't it I don't know finish it just
give yourself a head top to toe flick
okay scraping yeah I do a scraping Jesus
creeping know that you've got a lot of
you so Johnny's gonna hate this but I
think it minimizes you a towel oh I like
this ooh percent I've just in son shaded
this like since I was a kid
there we go so yeah it's just like a
natural it's like I read somewhere some
was a life hack spread ebon cheeks when
he said to have a poo you like well who
sits with the bum cheeks we've done this
before yeah so yeah these are like
natural so you flicking you flicking so
that you spend less time with the towel
and so that your towel doesn't get as
wet okay cuz I don't think it's all
really dries I think at all just stays
it takes wet yeah right I great okay
right I don't have to if you really are
right so I'm going to use one which is
for any potential land Lords or land
ladies out there or anyone else who
wants to work out whether someone is
taking care of a room or a property cabs
cameras is it's a bit of a blunt
solution to this probably illegal as
well I think it is so I've recently
purchased a new property which has some
tenants in it as a gift to the tenants
I've bought them a plant and
come on I've brought in a plant and in
that the point of the plant is if I go
into the house and the plants been
tended to it's been watered probably
pretty good indicator that nothing else
in the house needs looking at and I've
taken this idea from Martha if they
watch the podcast they don't watch it
actually [ __ ] no they do and they all
know who you are to find a block block
their IP okay so they're all they're all
medical students anyway so sure they'll
be sweet but the ID was taken from it's
either Foo Fighters or Aerosmith and
their sound manager put into their
hospitality rider so before a big artist
plays a show they'll have a big tech
rider and it will be this is the kind of
app system we need this is how many
guitar racks we need this is the height
of the step at the front for the lead
singer to step on and the lighting
system and all this sort of stuff and
then we what's referred to as a
hospitality rider which is food drink we
need these many Kiwis and some juice and
blah blah blah and it all gets sent over
to the promoter of the event organizer
and in deep in the depths of the
hospitality rider one of the sound tech
heads had put in that they wanted a bowl
of M&Ms with no blue ones it yeah and
that was being used as a canary in the
coalmine for if they've got no blue M&Ms
in the bowl they've definitely got the
[ __ ] lights and the sound and
everything else so he would George with
less scrutiny other things that are part
of the Ryder wherever at where us if
they have probably one's own they think
the question is in your situation so if
the canary dies you don't go in the coal
mine but if your plant dies what do you
do you look around the remainder of the
house with more scrutiny right are they
remembering to turn the extractor fan on
when they go into the bathroom are they
making sure that they're not leaving
water in the bath so like just other
things normal day-to-day how see things
so ideally you'd get
hence the I hate nature and hate plants
because then you know that if they're
managing the plant that everything else
is B oh your risk is that you have
tenants you love plants but couldn't
give a [ __ ] about damp in the bathroom
point good point baby hamster dead
hamster just that hamster or like a fish
fish tank
oh do I feed the fish the plant as a non
sentient being to me feels like a safer
bet mmm Johnny if he says get my cat
else so it's gonna say go what okay but
I haven't used it enough that's let's
hope that's hold off on that one cuz I
want to hear a proper experience and you
haven't I don't think you've used it for
long enough
okay I don't know this is a bit weak but
I'm gonna go for it go to you a
hairdressers it's no their new range of
Fitbit alright excellent what we got on
showcasing so this is a tie on so this
is a inspire HR I believe it's called
okay so the Fitbit that I use statement
resources human resources Fitbit human
resources the Fitbit the the older range
of fitbit's at least as far as I'm aware
that only that the only one was a
waterproof was the cheapest one which
had no screen it was just that was the
one I used to have the epithelia
remember banned banned with a little bit
in it I fit this it was fit in it
and that was what proof you get to a
minute so fly that on all the other ones
are more advanced ones that track your
heart rate stuff like that weren't
waterproof which is a [ __ ] on because
every time you have to have a shower we
take off and then you forget to put it
back on again etc I was walking the dog
and something happened that flipped the
Fitbit over and the bit came out and
this was like I think maybe in a day
later I just went like that time there
were no light sounds oh that's weird
bro squeeze it go how do you know that
it was when you're walking the dog well
that's the only thing that I can track
back there where so I think the
like flipped over because you don't you
know about you but my life isn't like
violent or there's not many things that
like yeah I could could have lost it so
as I have [ __ ] hey I'm enough to buy a
new one same price as this was eighty
quid
which is the same price as the old cheap
one school say I just want the bit just
a bit I don't want the face I don't mean
this is not the same
you've got the fit you can't go scream
at anyone don't think so I think they do
a pebble type thing they maybe maybe got
screamers yeah so talk me through what's
it called again what to do Fitbit in to
inspire HR there is an inspire which is
slightly cheaper but the inspire a child
is full shrine is a green light and your
wrists and then the green light shines
back mostly heart right yep so I've got
like better sleep data about a calorie
data better comes in heart rate tracking
similar to would but this stays on my
wrist the only reason that we can't get
you advanced stone is because you were
wearing it too slack and had the wrong
bandha it's it really pains me that you
weren't able to it wasn't able to have
enough time to like win you over because
if something is that was so basic and
obviously like the fact they is so
fundamental is exactly the problem but
the fact that you weren't able to like
it didn't have time when you were the
part that I don't understand about them
is why so that they use the same
technology as Fitbit I think well they
evaluate the individual yeah but it's
different fidelity but so it doesn't
there's not a need for the strap that we
passed there's no reason it couldn't be
this drop
for example right I don't know it's
always there it's comfort right cuz it
so I tried different Titus's your strap
and that strap could have one strap that
you should have out as the one that you
can't do in the UK Oh couldn't get but
you can now it's like they're fighting
against me hmm so I wanted it to work
will are mad who is the CEO he wanted me
wanted to work didn't reply to me about
my podcast invite either so I can just
learn you know what's great about we
actually they were just on Joe Rogan the
leave seemed like funding that had a lot
funding they just hit the market right
so my contract with whoop is up
and I'm not sure about whether or not
I'm going to renew Wow yes if that's the
only reason I don't expect the only
reason I'm not sure about whether or not
I'm goes allotment didn't well sorry
will Ahmed yeah come on what's yours
no no hold on sorry you can hit more
brother
just because I thought you were fully so
I do I do really like them but I liked
it a lot more when the I was getting it
off the back of referrals so right I
just don't know if it's worth that you
could a month to me do you do anything
with the data like if it said if it came
up when a flashing red like Chris Fox X
there in bed so it doesn't it doesn't
inform a training which is one thing I
think a lot of us are too pigheaded to
just I've got a training plan I'm
sticking to my training yeah if it's a
raster and even though I'm green I'm
gonna rest and if it's um yeah what
determines whether I train or not is can
I fit it in the week like one thing
that's one thing I said I will miss will
be the sleep tracking because when I
have thorn out of a room that means
enough sleep cycle which means that I
need to have a wearable of some kind
track my sleep I think the sleep
tracking on them for me when it's taking
my wrists all night we're better than
anything else I've tried here and
obviously the HRV yeah like pretty hard
to get HIV data involved it I split the
question is like as you say if it says
rest and you don't then well even like
is it accurate enough to predict like
all of the stuff going on with you
physically to say this is I'm my date is
more important than your training plan
and what you feel and all those things
and you should rest today it's just a
lot of thing on it it's just to inform
isn't it you're gonna get anything in
said again I'm considering that but I
don't want anything I don't like the
idea of anything that's a SmartWatch
like I don't want something that
displays text so an iWatch is out of the
question here I refused it like that
it's the battery life on them as well
David Charlie I've watched the after
charge daily yes is terribly so one of
the one of the guys that I was aware and
stuck to with recently was wearing a
Garmin very good Garmin and he uses his
four
everything for swimming and he said I
was like I don't want anything that
displays stuff and he's like I can just
turn off the link up for like phone
calls and text messages and stuff we did
you anchored and I could use that
because I'm swimming twice a week I
could use that and it'll it works out
your stroke rate your cadence your
length time your speed everything for
swimming which is pretty attractive and
then it links up with a heart belt which
will track your heart rate and that's
going to be more way more your hiss is
all over this yeah I've got my zone mz3
which does the job as well but that's
again that's another piece of tech and
there's something this quantified
self-movement is kind of cool but it
just screams virgin
to me it's one like does did you see the
post occur at the other day about like
the 22 year the 22 year old gym goer
virgin no have a look at it is it's very
nice very much all nice like coming in
and doing 120 six point five kilo
deadlift oh yeah yeah again that's
another like a power lifting like thing
or it means like I'm not gonna over
train I'm gonna have like these huge
rests I'm not going to like you know
even you as someone who I consider to be
as open-minded as you can get for a
power lifter mm-hmm for those since in
the beginning of the year refused to do
cardio with me because we were worried
it was gonna defeat your gains you're
the most secular ively of the power
lifters hasn't got a beard
it hasn't shaved his head yeah it's like
it's like how the music taste it I know
you know I have I think I know you do
too that you doubled scale yeah I try
but I just did it yeah but like neither
of us a dressed head was like or and I
feel the same way about I think any
community really part of things really
bad where people literally have all the
gear and no idea by they've been trained
for six months but they've got the best
own st every what he does not go at the
five years and train really hard in
Vegas it and like yeah a teacher without
a belt and
pack back three years of pack down and
then then you're allowed so this is
Johnny's like theory that everyone
should have a mandatory three years of
PEC deck and like like writers back
press because even right before you
started doing Crossfit so I bet those
people you see in CrossFit who you think
like you just need to pack definitely
press but a year then come back and
you'll get a lot more out crusher and
you can mock you in a bit back there
because it's just like your rite of
passage
dumbbell room is so a lot of lateral
raises yeah you totally right right not
Facebook's get your barbell row up to
160 oh yeah mote you fear most very
silky today yeah you're very soft
my fear is normally pretty good these
days I think stocking squatting then
still be squeegee so let me know again
if this is a repeat I need to sort my
for messing up this is a dental one and
this comes from a friend of mine called
hop in de who is a dentist and he said
if you're going to eat sweet foods eat
them all in one go so do not for God's
sake have like slow like don't graze on
sweets if you're gonna be sweet go big
or go home and do it in one block
because he said the the window of time
that sugar causes an insult to the teeth
is over 20 minutes and so if you eat
more sugar within that 20 minute period
there's no extra damage but you will
cause more damage by like if you have
like a skittle every 20 minutes then
you've completely there's our next thing
I get it from a dental perspective but
from a satiating puffs person
perspective it's completely contrary
yeah unlike a realism like living your
life it is but on that note oh and this
is not good for you but a chocolate bar
that I've rediscovered recently there is
not really the unsung hero of all
chocolate bars the picnic bar absolutely
beautiful like however what's what's it
contain come on so it's I think it's is
new got raisins and peanuts this would
kill you yeah in some kind of nut in a
kind of rocky texture
unfortunately review the master are very
low because they've made them smaller
and not
and get price the same which is a bit
noisy but I guess if you're interested
in lower calories then it's kind of good
but you could just eat less of a bigger
bar so yeah who eats part of one bar
well there's the problem isn't it like
the portion control or so much of the
obesity problem is bigger portions and
then people feeling because we're so
Puritan were obliged to finish our plate
and there's nothing in America man look
when I was in America you Cheesecake
Factory the [ __ ] size I cessationism
the starters were too big to finish yeah
Stas starts with two extension they had
a they had a salad a salad there was
2100 cows as a single serving single
serving one person main salad I mean
even if it's only main like that is
exceeding daily calories for those
people 2,100 Cal's
bun real bullet in the on the flip side
of that but it was delicious and the
well yeah probably was I didn't order it
and on the flip side of that they have
every single food every single meal has
the Carl's listed next to it including
drinks and they have a menu bigger than
some restaurants in the UK's menus of
like bites that are like under 600 Cal
and the [ __ ] loads have stuff in there
that was really nice
600 calories is still a pretty big meal
it's a main meal oh yeah yeah I mean
that's for a light bite would you rather
heart no no it's so it was they called
it like bites but it was just a main
that happens to be so no it was a full
meal like it was a salmon on like rice
with this and this and this or what I'd
rather have that I'd rather have all the
calories laid out even if every meal is
2,000 plus calories because then you can
just eat half of it but like I suppose
that predicates that you are able to
take a portion and not eat all of it but
I mean yeah I think that's quite
difficult but yeah the problem that I
see with Americans are America's food
crisis in general is that people are
making the wrong choices they have
they're better informed in America by a
real margin than we are of a for what
that was going in their mouth
and they're changing stuff now so they
can't have in happy meals for kids they
have to give them fruit and a juice they
can't give them fries and a soft drink
and I really less specifically requested
did you get a soft drink in any of these
like fast-food places so I was I when I
go to America I make a point of trying
all of the different as sweet zero
calorie teas I mean they're they're very
good Arizona ones just on everything
there's shitloads of different teas I
really like that they are good good um
yeah
iced tea with with sweetener in right
gets to get a couple of packets of
Splenda I think staying and I was just
saying because of like the sizes of the
you know at the paper or they got the
gallon that's like half gallons of
[ __ ] it's mental yeah like they're
small is easily our large like anyone
who's seen supersize me like they like
it yeah they're really good from the
supersize one is genuinely like huge
bucket right what do we got that done
okay so anyone who goes to the gym this
is the most optimal way to mix your
post-workout shake so most people and I
see this all the time in the gym people
go now and then may either have what's
it called where it's got the grating
what's that particular style of shaker
called the Kurata I know anyway so this
is this tooth there's two different two
main types one is where you've got a
little little ball and the other one is
where you have a great that goes across
the top of the shaker for either of
those shakers this strategy is the same
a lot for the whisk it's slightly more
effective you don't want to be doing a
linearly reciprocal motion this has to
be a hyperbolic parabola not far off
okay you want to twist here you want to
go and rotary you want to be going side
to side and the way that I know that's
true is the original use of the whisk in
the protein shaker that whisk was
actually made for whisking eggs so that
whole product wasn't built for protein
yes the little balls wispy balls into a
meringue was like whose bit was no sir
a much smaller bottle that had the whisk
in and on the original trademark for
that product the demonstration is like
this so side to side is much more
effective and it just he related
questions when you so imagine imagine
the picture the scene you're about to
shake protein shaker would you do with
you index finger on top always on top I
[ __ ] tell ya
there was a scene in uni me flatmate
audio broadcast were an audiobook
slavery people that have learned this
lesson the hard way yeah and that's just
instinctive now give a mixer protein
shake he put two scoops in for those
schools we screwed the lid on and then
just one like this and as he did that me
and the flatmate cover and he shakes it
obviously nothing happens but it's crazy
they're like the this erase erection
what your finger on the ligaments that
you've necessarily got someone who has a
strong arm flexors and it's like do
you're not violently and it's like but
it like the more modern ones so with the
with the whisk ball the lid does shut
down pretty firmly yeah but I give it a
proper I mean press it in it one was
really person so have you transitioned
to steel shakers yet no I've got so I
keep hearing about this though thank you
to the protein works for giving Johnny
his new steel shaker which I will give
him once we finish this province has to
but it's anyone who's out there is
listening and I go that I leave is the
gold one or the silver one orange matter
and Oh fantastic metal 1 metal matte
orange so it smell but they smell a lot
less much significantly easier to clean
it's just the fact that if you drop it
it's like you know when you drop one a
plastic one you always like like is it's
about a the floor this is just
bulletproof a penny you over time it
gets dense which is actually like pretty
cool and like is it a rustic feel pretty
hardcore so I've been I mean it won't
apply much now because of summer but
I've been putting hot water in mine
cuz in the plastic one hot water and
plastic bad idea but just fill it up
with hot water or tea take it to the gym
warms your hands up on the way in
especially the transition to metal um
yeah because our cycle to the gym as
well so obviously like if you it is cold
outside you can't move your hands
properly tennis elbow plastic plastic
shakers and hot liquid and the jury
feels wrong but that's really cold day
it's so lovely I think having a cold
drink when it's like like brass tennis
pickles cold is I've got to two elements
there little ancillary bits to doing a
shaker definitely anyone who wants to
buy one because they are fantastic and
they continue to support the podcast
there will be a link to the steel shaker
from the protein works in the show notes
below and also they will include a
discount code if I can find one the
first thing is when I spoke about the
trademark patent for it you ever seen
the original patent for the toilet roll
holder no this finishes the debate about
whether or not the toilet roll should be
set to go over the top or under the bars
it shouldn't even be a debate yeah I
know hey what do you think in front over
the top so that it's closest to you
yep yes exactly exactly and that's how
the original patent is a psychopath test
yes it's the original patent is filed
right so this is closest to you yeah
right gonna send it
oh how do you even do it over that let's
buy in the back how do you adjust its
difficulty like you've got to what do
you mean
so need these more limbs doesn't it to
like anchor in place no I don't dude you
have to hold it yes it's a pull and yank
yeah to the side mmm I still see grunts
you still be able to do that for
something decide to go fish behind it
and like to talk with presuming there's
not a little bit hanging done I always
now play the game of like can i I don't
need to know just I don't a second hunt
yeah yeah just sign yeah but it's far
there's a game yeah big downside though
except oh I mean I was gonna say have
you ever got it wrong if you ever get it
really really wrong control is it always
surprises me how quickly
if you try and roll it back up you never
get it the same Oh miles here it's this
like soft mess yeah
does Dexter not like do that on toilet
roll and I animal seem to love like
unraveling toilet rolls yeah how do we
go into that Chris's typical shaves his
pattern punt thyroid what we got I know
on the sound I mean we can't be running
on empty for life hacks man well I
always expect so I do have one that it's
not really a lie [ __ ] the the tip is
just some ovens see see see Chris
doesn't like some ovens because he's not
someone that doesn't look like it but
why don't you like some of inscript
massive virgin he's got a wife massive
virgin okay
since ah this is a massive virgin pick
Chris but an interesting guy on YouTube
I think it's great get more ones but
what one a video is thrown some ovens do
you think that everyone should watch
you're gonna get one crack at this and
I'm not gonna let you do it again things
I wish I'd learned in my twenties I mean
it depends what depends on the person's
interested in I mean that Johnny we've
got one you've got one just go on his
YouTube no you have one what else I need
two most popular video is easy to run at
that time just what's up so the because
though I [ __ ] audience would like say
the things I wish I know like hmm the
the 20 times all about business okay no
the online business one's really good
his chaos series is really good his
productivity stuffs really good
my last we interpret a busy one was good
what's the one on productivity
someone's on YouTube productivity cool
right it's gone
so again tell me this is a repeat if
someone in this is a submission from
Tess if you're watching Tess please she
cut you know very good no so she is a
nurse in the Freeman hospital and her
tip was if you see a man doing a poo in
a plastic bag in a cubicle get
aggressive immediately that is the way
to stop it
so she open key
cool curtain saw a man during a period
passing by you are not to get out of
there you're doing it the toilet and she
immediately won on the attack and I
think that is an incredible response to
had she actually have tried to broach
the subject with more diplomacy Oh
anyone who continued booing yeah it
would've been a mess but he was so
shocked by her being immediately on the
offensive why okay so this is a man in a
hospital yeah but he why was he cooing I
was unwell mentally and well no not
mentally unwell and not ill enough to
have to to not be able to make it to the
so what was it he was only a cubicle in
you know in like a in a Bay
I thought you meant in a toilet in a
toilet cubicle no in just in a bed Bay
so if you're in a hospital
yeah and you see someone in a hospital
bed think this is wide enough for enemy
to be gained from this which i think is
like she had the the wherewithal to just
immediately go for it and so another
example your friend who is the captain
of the Newcastle Falcons saw some bother
going on immediately run over picked up
I said two ranchers got it got it got
involved and just put them in a bleep in
a wheelie bin know who you've been yeah
so so just for the dispensing which I
say just so when you see a problem
don't try and just well it's only if you
have to try and deal with it you may be
sticking your nose in and commit it
overly committing to something that you
don't need to that there's a lot of
delicacy that's it I think this is a
good life hack for someone who's
probably over the age of like 25 or 30 I
think somebody was 18
with the BT trigger-happy yeah yeah
they're gonna pull the trigger to sister
so my my sister says don't half fight
anyone which is a I mean she's a bit of
a fighter but I think bless you but that
makes sense though where it's like you
wouldn't if you went up to someone in
the street and you just kind of like
bonked them on the nose yeah but not
like broccoli you're gonna end up in a
much worse situation than if you just
absolutely like know
it's I think it's justa but you
shouldn't go on assaults I think legally
you'd be in a better position you just
gave a little bunk
really what is it so it might go from
assault GBH where you go from it being
like a misdemeanor to you in a jail it's
just fine I know I think I know what you
saying and it doesn't have to be about
fights I suppose it's just about like
doing any commits to do it properly do
underpass oh I feel so bad for you
running out of life hacks max I'm just
looking at a list that's longer than the
list I've given today you need I will I
really think both of us is just reflect
both of us are adamant about the fact
that you're mm-hmm barrier for what you
consider to be a life hack is too high I
think if you live many blind spots that
you do a great service
all right between ifox episodes not much
changes in what I do but within the
productivity realm I think you do you've
got that down because you're operating
under no constraints which people think
is great but actually it's the hardest
operators productivity on hard paradigms
of choice Emmitt yeah cuz you wake up in
this like I could just stay in bed and
no one would notice so bright so I am
gonna do a final one and it's quite nice
when I actually are we interested to
hear both of your thoughts on Drive
without any music or sound play so a lot
of but certainly in this room all of us
will be optimization evangelists trying
to oh I've got this drive I'm not doing
anything else or datura Lee I can use
this time to learn or catch up on
something or listen to some music that
gets me in a mood which is optimal for
what I'm about to do maybe if you go in
here to him that's how I do but recently
I have read digital minimalism by calmy
poor and in digital minimalism he gives
a fantastic definition of solitude you
remember that vaguely
so solitude is a time when your mind is
free from the input of other minds and
that's different to being on your own
and also different to being lonely
loneliness is something which is
unhealthy and time on your own where you
still have the input of other minds is
not solitude sees walking as an example
do you have for long walk
yes one of the things that yes but um
yes I've just been doing a drive again
I've been stunted into my day so mine is
now a part of my morning routine so my
morning drive to the gym is done in
silence and that will be after I've
journaled meditated read a book and
potentially done some deep work so if
there was ever a time to sit in silence
and reflect about what's just gone on
and how I'm gonna spend my day ahead and
stuff like that it's then and I have to
say driving without any music on and
without any sound on is actually really
nice and engaging
taking in a little bit more of the
scenery allowing myself to bookend
whatever learning I've just gone through
its
I'd be interested to see if you guys
implement it how it works for you I know
that I said occasionally because well
like driving is even on it on its own
quite a complex task but after like a
year a year after passing your test to
kind of forget that it was ever hard
yeah but there's so much going on that
if you make to make it you know a 17
year old just learning to drive playing
some loud metal music it's not go over
well yeah what I want I I think I'd do
it automatically after training because
I just like after training I just like
one of a chill-out - when people leave
me alone you know I hear usually just
been listening to heavy stuff that's
what powerlifting will do I guess with
sit like frying your cns so bad
especially if you use like lifting heavy
yeah I've seen you've had like loud
music heavy stimulus I don't want like a
podcast or a book or music just quiet
yeah but it's not I probably not getting
the same benefit as yeah
when you're in a freshness state of mind
yeah I'd be interested if you would if
you're a doctor I'd be really interested
to see how you feel or maybe when you do
your morning walk I've been doing a few
walks but by accident
silence yeah like my my phone will be
long battery your oh [ __ ] how's the new
airports
I don't um we heard it first here guys I
fight in the edifice I think that the
fact that you haven't come in singing
and dancing about upon twos means that
well so how do I not washed my hair pods
I wouldn't have boy iPod tubes put it
that way
why didn't you buy a pod what arc is
your inquisitiveness looking back do you
wish that you'd save to 30 or 40 quid um
so I think they'd be better if I hard I
don't think I could live with himself
but that was one when I paused to yeah
you would have done as you have already
had them and now with the benefit of
hindsight so okay so that the hey Cerie
functionality is cool so he she just
loves it that's so responsive so he very
hey Siri hey there you go
I think that's just the slowness of you
but yeah well if Mike it might be that
you got quite an old phone for Kurans
teeth haha come on back hot on an audio
baby it's about so that that
functionality is really cool I asked
someone else about the double tap left
double tap right yeah he told me that
they their feature there our pod ones
don't have skip songs on they're not
using the function in the functionality
record it's in safe settings humbly and
this is been this me Ben bass program
Ben isn't using it right yeah I'll put
that to bed sorry that your your app is
not temperamental an IV or ear pods
they're a piece of technology just the
same as the rest of ours
he really squeezes the lemon with the
Apple infrastructure and he uses it to
its end I'm afraid I see yours we have
fast either we have found where the
rubber meets the road my friend so
anyway so but for that feature for me
was cool because for me that was a
revenge got my phone up hey hello do you
know what's happening tomorrow I'm
actually getting a new phone I can't do
the noggin a kid so so what I was gonna
say what good say was if I had an iPhone
X or whatever with chopped wireless
charging and I had a wireless charging
mat you'd get a lot of benefit although
I think being otherwise he charge your
headphones which is nice it's just it
for me induction charging you
is such a gimmick the only thing that I
can see that works for induction
charging is what to come out on those
new son songs where you can charge yeah
we can share charge between phones so if
I've got a hundred percent him you've
got like ten percent you can tailor some
of my yards yeah and that is for not
being able to charge your headphones on
the phone okay yes so charging us the
charging other devices from them on a
device which currently doesn't charge at
the devices but all that you need is a
lightning to lightning cable and for
Apple to have that in an iPhone you know
why don't they do that that doesn't
exist as it no right no if I'm able to
get a beam one but I don't think you can
even Elance send charge rather stands
charged I think it would just be like
you'll be sucking power out of both of
them she's bad addition if it's zero on
both so that that functionality is nice
but they are the same they're the same
as closure I am the next time that we do
a life hacks all other X s max the the
the pro pro one like that a lot I like
best
yes big what sizing this sofa yeah like
so I'll see I will be able to be
interesting so back has gotten X I think
nor legs yeah
so if I like not having that button
takes a while like just when you're
using it yeah and you have to use the
side button a lot more and your market
with your face and all stuff I imagine
once he used to it it's gonna miss I'm
gonna miss having the home button but
it's game very is for one was it it was
really cheap there you got it for one
pound effectively because of the or for
a one pound cheaper than it was it was a
black friday like vodafone deal he
basically got the overlap of about
twelve different discounts or the one
again the problem with those that we're
buying our sim free mean Darnley both be
going into BIOS in free without contract
and the contract start with separately
so to these years keeping the same thing
keeping the same case everything bison
free move everything across like that
again for anyone who's listening that's
a [ __ ] fantastic live hacked by you
thought if you've got the cash by your
phone out right yeah because the deal
that you can get
your contract you're paying over the
odds to finance the phone from someone
who's not built finance films well I
will don't realize when they take out
consumer credit which is what it is when
you are the page up to pay your
insurance monthly or you get a phone
contract that's monthly and you get the
third for free is that you're taking up
an extremely high interest loan and a
sub quality so yeah contract deal and
overpriced contract to you what you get
but because people don't really analyze
that people don't multiply out the time
you're at your game absolutely rinsed
aren't people used to paying like 30
quid a month or whatever for their
phones everything is just missing the
next phone some phone companies mine
nearly did this to me once you reach the
end of your they just go back they keep
charging you at the rate that you've
been paying so we can increase since you
hate the phone off technically that's
the debt pay [ __ ] they continue
just billing you for we quit so what you
have to bring them and say don't grade
me to a similarly so contract you need
to use bill monitor which I can't
remember but might have been black box
101 no spoken with you ah okay
but I'm [ __ ] is this like Toby
this is developed developed by Oxford
mathematicians god it's like it's an
algorithmic market search you put in the
constraints or you you give them the
login for your previous contract data
your usage it's a Sony for phones
further phones yeah so minutes versus
minutes allowance versus minutes used
data etc and it finds what is the best
contract or combination of offers across
any network and you set do you want Sims
reads you want contract do you want how
much data do you want or whatever but
ultimately you just put it all in and
it'll it'll just generate it for you
based on your usage apples means a
radiant feature is awesome so this is
going be trading missing tomorrow I'll
give you like 10 quid for it though 275
code which is 20 quid more than music my
pride calm will give me another amazing
lap I would be written as well there I
got rid of my last one these hard cars
not bad what would it sell on
before or while refurbed one yeah from
now it's probably long are we 500 quid I
can't do it that way and I'm not I can't
be bothered with eBay I can't be
bothered with Facebook okay well good if
he if you just want no admin yeah and
it's in the realm like you're only gonna
get it so 275 for that but through the
difference though well okay I don't know
so - drew quit - meantime I don't think
the difference is that make you know I
don't think is there befallen I would
actually maybe maybe even last because
if people don't want like typically
that's a seven plus that's like three
years old though you probably get an X
or an eight but I think if you go much
old because that you run into software
problems yeah because to get grant
dollars I'll just price them out of the
mine mines starting to get problems but
this has been the longest lasting one
like three years just under three years
over three years in September with the
same phone so this it's exactly the same
right when he's getting battery issues
and so I've replaced the battery in mine
on the last day the last day that Apple
Care exists all right yeah consumer law
can see well you love consumer law
that's what happens when you've got
friends that work in Apple they replace
things on the consumer they do it
because I was looking because you know
the the most expensive MacBook yes sixth
oh I was seeing what is the most
expensive MacBook to respect the [ __ ]
thing and it is like six and a half
round but they do a but they do it they
do a MacBook traded which I've sweated
in used to do so when you when your
Rockets check out on this heads would
you like to trade in a MacBook and you
put in your serial number yeah and they
give you
yep I think of mine was like five
hundred quid or something I've just
missed that them they don't do what you
mean like I yeah sure you sold it you
look got warmer than an ebay nightmare
though edgy Harmon yeah can we talk
about it
yeah you outside of the libelous window
for it probably other there's no such
thing I mean it you're like it was the
guy's fault but I sold a macbook and
drenched in porn i'm i just dig my porn
so it said like these are the specs here
here and here it is working and it was
fine I had the motherboard replaced no I
tested it worked absolutely fine did all
the like proper the proper Apple
diagnostic tests through the thing
included the results on that guy I
bought it he was a tech guy and I think
he'd been tampering with it 48 days
after buying it
he sent me a photo of the UH pervert
working saying like oh the battery's not
very good it's like well yeah it's a six
year old laptop and it set I said on the
thing like included the battery health
from the number of cycles and stuff and
the following day he was are now it
doesn't turn on at all you're like oh
that's that's interesting the day after
he sent me a picture of it working 49
days after you bought it it's suddenly
not working at all and he's like I want
a refund it's like well I don't really
know like what you expected like oh
sorry it's failed but it was working
when I sold it to you
devices and he escalated it to eBay and
then eBay like no escalated the PayPal
[Music]
if you had drew cut down on paper no
people ruled in my favor
Oh cuz they were like just got simpler
be more something that yeah yeah so I I
think what he'd done is he tried to like
play with the thing himself broke it and
I was like oh good so I sold my before
my current laptop I saw the map book on
eBay to a guy sounds very similar to
that and I had an argument with him in a
car park they called me a scoundrel
it's a scoundrel yeah said you absolute
scoundrel I said this guy I mean she'll
garage car park at Newcastle at war
dealing with this guy's in person I met
him in person yeah as opposed to mailing
it yeah well he was relatively local so
he driven to though any nut shell shell
garage Newcastle Airport there is a
certain type of person
see of people that buy second-hand mark
yeah and I've realized a bay is much
more of a headache than it gets and they
charge like a fifteen thirty percent
Facebook marketplace that can find out
where you work
oh yeah true and what did he say he was
just like he was picking the whole thing
apart and I just sat there thinking like
this is getting to the point now when
this wasn't worth it like when you net
eBay fees and the time like the Russians
he had about it before we got to this
point and they're quite like questions
now and just think like I think I think
I saw it was in that book they love an
inch thing I thought what do you expect
like you you getting it so I just I just
think people who buy stuff like that
that's quite old and very like off pace
of what's available yeah they're just a
certain type of person they're already
trying to drill down in this various
possible yeah yeah but they want it's
the same as the people who sign up for
your six pound one of course and also
complain about the fact it's not fully
perfect yeah I Jen doesn't Inc involved
like a personal call once a week
hey this this doesn't have 3,000 pounds
worth of coaching in how this expand but
Apple just avoid all of this something
but just pricing them so they just are
like things are expensive and you can
afford it you can't and enough people
can follow that they don't need to deal
with their mind the general the general
public likes sometimes when I get
exposed to the general public like you
places like planes and Airport like
waiting waiting but planes is the big
one because you're forced to know in a
container I was under the train house
messaging you guys for the stern I was
on a train and the Train picked up some
young partygoers in New York and dropped
them off in Darlington and I heard for
the entirety of the journey from your to
Darlington
I heard them argue about whose house
they were going to have the pre-party at
like the whole way I'm just like look
guys I don't wanna go all podcasts for
me here but life actually is too short
and if yours isn't too short the mind
[ __ ] is and by the way this is B
coach which is the quiet coach so can
everyone leave I was just yeah people
choosing to go on the quiet coach
just have gesticulation about this and
there was one girl of this whole like
situations sensory assault as well in
the have hairspray and you're like oh
yeah whose multimedia not only like
three yeah I know this one girl kept on
saying so they were talking about are
they gonna have it at dance house are
they gonna have it at Chris's house Dan
one-a-day his house when Chris wanted it
his house
no Chris mint we're gonna have it at my
house and then he turn or danmit we're
gonna have it at mine but every time
that Chris said we're gonna have it at
my house his girlfriend piped up and
said our house Chris every single time
we're gonna have it at my house our
house we're gonna have it at my house
like the whole time I was like surely
she's gonna give up here every time that
he said it she corrected him I'm like
that play to that girl like draw lines
in the Sun we said it in relationships
101 bright lines I kind of get the
impression that you and Chris are gonna
last that long maybe Chris was
clinically death this is done my house
and that's why they weren't in a quiet
coach because they thought they'd be
because I thought it was silent and it
was I've witnessed you surf so we were
on the way back from I think London
becoming where we've been and it was
noisy and it got some people got on the
train really drunk
and they still I started Sweet Caroline
through and I could just watch the tide
just go 18 leaflets all over again I
just let it go let it go and he's like
yeah hey you're right continue talking
and then I would say something and have
to say it again and when I said it again
I just saw him go can you straight down
the pipe of that camera and in the
microphone so the listeners at home here
can you explain the thing that Yusuf
does we're about to deliver some news
that you know someone doesn't say
there's almost like a multiple gasps of
breath ders
so what I want you I think it's faster
than that I think it's the frequencies a
bit more likely no it's not it's
definitely it what do you think it's do
you - I think it's like vestige from
what I used to have a stutter when I was
little so that would be your warm alive
yeah so sometimes certain syllables
wouldn't come out so you have to almost
trick your brain into either pretending
you're gonna sing the syllable yep or
like take an inhale what it looks like
is you're just looking for a space in
the conversation to say something he
doesn't look like it take on it that's
good that's us then what you see that
happen it's like oh get down I don't
mean this in a nasty way he said
something like can you keep it down a
bit please mate and this the carriage
litter ease when no noise and there was
if they and and then the couple he'll go
like yeah who's keep it down and like
the woman that was with the couple when
like see I told you but men and
literally this the carriage wasn't
silenced it you're a man of the pizza
man well like they were being so
temperature SM noise other thing yeah
Canada by well I've got PTSD from flying
to New York years ago because someone in
front of me was doing like the most they
must have had like a toxic megacolon
it was like is that the medical term oh
it was like like a big piece of
punctuation KFC puffs puffs Oh for a
five-hour flight can you think of a
particular medical issue that they might
have had can you name as a medical issue
with
probably like irritable bars like if
they're not is there not a funnier
wording one some some really might have
been glands related clitoral megali
negra
have you considered it might have been
clitoral mega we know it may well have
been but that does tends not to be
characterized by a fried-chicken like oh
very I reckon for the whole joke what is
it like fire hose or something they kept
doing sir tonight yeah I mean fair
enough like the can't fly anywhere else
but that's a really good point they can
you're not fart inside because it's ours
or a plane almost more selfish to get up
every time go the toilet the fart is it
if you what think how often you'd have
to ask the person actually to move and
choose an aisle seat if you get as far
as using I'll see I've got so many
traveling ones that I've got over the
last week
I am I we may have to theme the life
huckster I reckon I'll get Johnny's
juice yeah that's what I need I need so
I'm not feeling the life sucks man
you're just gonna start taking him down
people like to pick and mix nature right
I'll try my best so um I'll finish on
this yesterday I was on a plane back
from New York and there's a guy's sat
behind me and I didn't turn around and
look properly so I put my seat in leaned
it back and then immediately felt like
some movement in my lower back and I was
like it's a bit weird he wasn't have
soit his stuff up
I know then I heard him say something
pretty quickly after had done it I
turned around it was maybe a late
forties American man who said something
to be effective why have you moved your
seat back and I said that's what the
button was for said what no one else on
the planes moved their seat back you can
move your seat back just as much and
then we're all so I then said to him I
was like look I'm not moving their seats
back I'm moving my seat back then just
went back to reading my book freedom
eBook
ten minutes of constant movement in my
lower back and I thought this guy must
have brought his knees up to his chest
to annoy me or something I'm like how
infantile is this guy number even still
reading the book enjoying it always get
someone that but yeah that's what I was
thinking
surely not anyway turned round and I
said after 10 minutes I'm like a little
bit agitated me zones getting lost is
there an issue lightly is there a
problem it's this it's that you sat next
to his daughter and wife as well so and
I'm like look like it sir is there an
issue and he said look at this just
there's not a lot of room here I see a
long man so he I had already made a
decision I'd already made the decision
to myself I was just gonna move my sita
i was like i would much sooner have my
journey in peace then have to interact
with this man and I think that that
generally in itself is a good heuristic
to use for these sorts of situations
like yes your seceding ground and maybe
you shouldn't but immediately it's not
about win and lose it's not about he's
got the victory and you've got the loss
it's about the fact that you were at
peace with your situation and that to me
was much more satisfying if you have to
sit more upright it's like a bit more
upright but I don't have his knees in my
back anymore and it totally not gonna
say when you moved it back that he had
his head down for something she didn't
get worse than that no so I eat and he
said him I'm 6 foot 4 like any like sure
enough that he couldn't move his knees
out the way and I hadn't even move my
see all the way back 6 foot 4 then the
lady came round and got some drinks and
he passed me a coffee and said thank you
very much for that and then when he went
to sleep said I'm gonna sleep with my
legs out to the side in the aisle
because we're both in the aisle like
feel free to move you seat back now and
then asking me a bunch of questions
about how easybring London for his
family when we got off the plane at the
end and I thought did he buy you a
coffee or did he just get one it was a
very it was a free coffee but she'd run
out of coffee at him as the gesture she
was gonna turn around and go back and
she was like god I wasn't just trying to
shock you sleep with caffeine ya mean
just through her mother but yeah I think
from that I was like yeah let's deceive
a little bit ground and just enjoy that
and then on top of that as well the
actual final outcome of it was me
feeling like that guy had a nice journey
I didn't do this and we improved a bit
International Relations it's if you're
gonna sell the seven quid and now it's
in this ten thirty six now yeah story to
finish so before we go
do not forget please head to iTunes and
give us five star rating don't forget to
leave a review and you could be the
lucky recipient of one of these two six
Mary's thank you very much to your best
self if you'd like to get hold of one
they will also be a link to that in the
show notes below on top of that any
questions or comments that you have just
fire them at me actress well acts on all
social media or a prop in Fitness in the
comments on YouTube and all of that good
stuff thank you very much for tuning in
and we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you